but I only got paid because I made a
company but I didn't get paid off views
I never got paid off views like YouTube
still well I mean I'm sure a lot of your
content is not monetizable well they
were it was monetized for three years
but
you know that little bar which shows
your money mine was transparent but it
had the money
and I never got it
what I've talked about the lawyer I've
talked to that do ddg yeah talk to Hank
is a big YouTuber talk to DJ ghost
they're like what are you saying to me
and I showed him like I thought you were
[__] lying like no look look it
did you apply for monetization it was
monetized so you like you got approved
approved like you got the Google AdSense
I have a Google AdSense up to my bank
account and every month it just says
zero in the Google AdSense but on
YouTube it you could see a number and
there's just a nut waiting for you to
get paid I mean one day if anybody else
say it now if anybody can give me my
money I will give you 30 of it it's
almost it's 3.1 million dollars just
sitting there I never got it why [__]
they kept it they were running ads on
all my [__] about age restricted and
then they were running
Ross and press ads on my videos that I
can't
on my rosin press video they were
running rosin press ads wait what year
was the rosin press thing 2019 oh yeah
this is crazy so there was like a big
Purge I got I got YouTube a year after
because I heard about the YouTube Purge
which was like yeah which was about 17.
yeah exactly or 16. I heard about that
but I was like bro I just can't tell
can't we get paid
and then they like yo we'll pick up some
contacts at YouTube please help me heck
I'll help you bro I will I swear to God
you can take 25 to 30 percent of this
chunk of money if you can get me my
money back just because it's like I
don't think it's that hard of a fix go
buy something with it we just want to
buy some property yeah that's a that's a
that's a lot of money
dude I try not to get mad every time you
log into YouTube you're looking at it
like no about two years ago they stopped
it and it just said zero zero oh so
there's is there any last year said
monetize is gone but I mean I was
Monitor and they were running Donald
Trump uh ads on my [__] for president
I never got no money from that what the
[__] that shit's insane intervention or
uh rehab ads all the time on my [__]
it's crazy crazy yeah I got a second
Channel that I don't smoke or cuss and
they they just demonetize that too
really it's a drug content
okay what about your podcast Channel
demonetized
every every episode's age restricted and
when you when you try to press it it
says are you sure you want to watch this
this is this is a concert yesterday I
clicked one and said this contains
suicidal content
the 80 one I just did yeah
have you considered uh well I wouldn't
say not smoking because we have smoke we
have episodes of people smoking it's
monetized have you considered
editing out curse words for the first
like 10 minutes we have a 10 guy nice
car oh I've seen that many of you guys
nothing
now bet pixels the people that help out
all the comedians they were like brah
they were trying to help and they never
I wonder if they just have like a I have
a Blacklist on my name they might have
100 dude because I've gotten delete off
of Vimeo or the video which was like the
old school like via Vimeo where if you
were like a video editor you'd post your
reels on or you got kicked off of that
for promoting the sale of drug content
or the sale of drugs and harmful Goods
what I don't even know you can get
kicked off that that [__] is crazy I get
[__] with a lot dude like a lot so
I saw recently that you're picking up a
sponsors on your podcast yeah we just
opened up to we sponsors finally because
I never did because I wanted to show
YouTube like look I can be the podcast
guy too I don't have to be the weed guy
on here
so there's there's a lot of episodes you
don't even smoke because I asked the
guests do you smoke no do you mind if I
smoke well I don't mind like don't worry
I can even box you don't worry we won't
even smell there's a lot of episodes we
don't smoke I was gonna say uh and
they're age restricted so at the moment
you guys haven't been able to really
fully monetize the podcast I know you
guys had like a a small deal because I
saw some episode where you were talking
about how
um you were working with was it a
network yeah we signed with uh a company
they do like say it's this compound yeah
so here's our set there's Tyson there's
Matt Barnes there's Tony Hawk and like
we walk in do our it's like a TV thing
it just didn't work out that's all
nothing bad just me and Marty looked at
each other how long does that deal
indefinite and then we were like at
three months we're like
Marty we can work way harder and faster
than this and he's like I know
so we're like hey guys we're just gonna
go back and do our thing we appreciate
you we left nothing wrong on their part
just if me and Marty's Marty Works
harder than I do and I work my ass off
and it's just if we can do this
let's just do it ourselves is your squad
a two-man Squad it's just me Marty dude
so Marty handles the editing he handles
editing
the back end stuff so he's like
uploading he's uh um yeah yeah he's
uploading the if we see a social media
clip he's handling that as well yeah
Marty's completely taken over the
podcast since we left the agency and
came back so he's just on it he's doing
a great job he's doing a great [__]
job dude I just go hosting yeah Marty's
just the man bro he really is uh do you
know about Marty or no I just followed
him once I kind of um dived into your
world and I saw he you know he's like I
got a Graphics Company and but he's the
most Apple guy in the world
um I met Marty so he does graphics for
Joe Rogan and Shannon yeah he DM me and
I went for real because he hit me up one
day and goes I had her in one of my
story times ago was this would you guys
watch a podcast if I did one right it's
like 2019 I said it yeah
and then I got a bunch of comments
saying [__] yeah I'd watch it all right
that day I posted it Marty dm'd me
and said hey I do podcasting this and
that and this I've been following you
about five years but I saw and that's
what made me happy like oh you didn't
just bug me and say let's work yeah like
what the [__] do I do Roofing like shut
up that doesn't help right now you're
gonna be like people do that to you I
get I guarantee oh yeah yeah but Marty's
like I do podcasting I just watched your
video five minutes ago and I'm like if
you ever want to start and then Marty's
like uh ticket sales Graphics promo
online [__] for Rogan theovan and
Corolla but he helped start the fighter
and the kid so he's like the guy oh he
helped start that helped he helped with
my Brandon yeah and then so I'm looking
at him like
you want to help me start a [__]
party I just get high on the internet
yeah you know
and um it took a long time he started he
took over my YouTube videos Marty's the
best editor on YouTube I will say that
right now he crushes me your videos are
sick Bro the production value
marketing is crazy I'm like dude you
guys are kind of running circles around
a lot of thank you man and again like I
said I was very ignorant to your uh
podcast
so it was dope to like when I saw the
Trap I was like yo this podcast looks
sick I love your guys's [__] sad
thank you and then I followed you guys
and I was like uh when the Jeezy thing
popped up I watched that and I just
loved your your approach I loved your
non-hip-hop approach to that interview
yeah I wanted to bring out like what
else did people not ask you because the
thing is is like Jeezy's gonna run
around and do every hip hop podcast and
they're gonna approach him on the
hip-hop side and you approached him just
wanted some life [__] like hey I checked
your book out like I I always want to
ask I asked a lot of guests if 16 year
old you walks in are they gonna beat the
[__] out of you or you got them right
because that gets gas going what and
then the girls makes them reflect and
they go
I was wild and then it makes I feel like
it breaks the eyes of like
hey you know we're nice we're chilling
you just talk because you know a lot of
famous [__] do a lot of interviews
and a lot of people are very uh you know
they're especially a guy like Jeezy
Jeezy's probably got his guard up in a
lot of interviews because he's [__]
cheesy I can't always see when it goes
down yes it's about minute five you
gotta ease him in yep yeah that's what
we try to do here because like obviously
we're a hip-hop podcast but like we
aren't like other platforms where I
would say that like we're not a
controversy driven
controversy at all so it was like it you
know
I won't say like we just had Adam 22 on
him Adam 22 challenged ad on our [__] he
went hard yeah he did but the thing is
like I'm friends with both of them so
like I'm trying to kind of like I had me
I don't think I don't know what's going
to happen would you do that in real life
no he wouldn't [__] hate you guys
should you guys should box you know what
he said about you so I'm not gonna do it
on my show also like I feel if I can
just do well and do everything without
that
I mean it kind of like stamps the like
nah good conversation people just kind
of want to watch I'm like